We're gonna get there,
get in line.
Um,
yeah.
I might have to get in line.
I'll do whatever I have to do.
What are you,
I'll probably get the bug and then just want it badly.
I like it,
man.
I'd be willing to wait in line for like an hour.
No,
half an hour.
Oh,
all right.
I was like,
let's see which,
just thinking about how long does it take,
how long has this line?
Half Hour.
Just order.
If you ordered,
they just ship it to you,
but you got the same day when you wanted them immediately.
But what will hold me over is that Samsung Galaxy s three.
I want to see it yet,
which I've heard good things.
Yeah,
I'll pull it out.
I'll let you touch it.
Did have somebody at a show.
I want to touch it.
Uh,
take,
take a picture with it and the screen look beautiful.
It's insane.
And you know what else it can do?
It can take a blast of photos.
I can take our really 10 photos in a row.
Got High speed.
Yeah,
it does some weird thing.
Where can,
you know,
jump up in the air and it'll capture the cow 10 different pictures.
It's amazing.
Like if a,
the deer
did,
I got my back yard for wanting to get photos of them.
Them went to the bathroom,
they were going full on,
running fast back and forth,
like for no reason.
And I'm like,
what?
What are these guys doing?
This run around your house is surrounded by crazy deer.
Yeah,
but they're a,
this is like where they feel comfortable cause my dogs can't get Watson.
Then the nice animals,
who cares?
You're ready.
You ever said lucky?
They're lucky that uh,
it's not illegal to shoot him.
Yeah.
Would you shoot him?
Oh,
here's a problem.
Here's the problem with deer.
It's not a problem in my neighborhood cause nobody drives fast.
You know,
it's a pretty quiet area.
But if you,
if you have this many deer near a main road,
it becomes a real problem.
People all over the world crashing the deer.
I mean,
it's just a fucking really common way that people get injured in cars get fucked
up,
fucked up.
I fucked up,
ruined different deer that big.
Do you think of that?
How big that Deere was and if that hit the windshield,
that's break your fucking face man.
Yeah.
And if the thing is still alive and kicking and glasses,
flying your eyeballs,
if it was a motorcycle,
yeah,
you,
you literally have to kill those things.
You have to kill them.
And there's the,
Peta people don't want to admit this,
but this one of two options.
Okay.
You either assume your position at the top of the food chain and deal with the
problem or you bring something else in and you're no longer at the top of the
food chain because that's the only way you're going to have to deal with this
issue.
What do they pray everywhere.
So you either eat it or you bring in predators.
That's all you can do.
Cause you're either going to shoot it or you got to bring in mountain lions and
wolves.
So they propose that we just let deer just exploded in population.
Yeah.
Well they,
you know,
look,
they don't want people hunting.
Right?
They don't want people hunting.
But I don't know what kind of ideas they have,
the desktop,
the population growth.
Because if you don't manage that shit,
and this is something that,
you know,
when I was a young man I thought that like deer hunting.
Like wow,
why would you ever want to kill a deer?
I didn't even think about the irony of wanting a cheeseburger and,
and,
and not,
you know,
in wondering why anybody would go and kill a deer.
Like it didn't even make sense to me.
But as you get older and you understand that you have to do something about the
population,
if you don't do something about the,
they are like rats.
The,
that's how every there's going to be a disease.
There's going to be problems because every population needs to be put in check.
The cycle has to be the reason why the world so fucked up right now is because
there's nothing that eats us.
That's like the main reason we can just dominate.
We can just run around all willy nilly and nothing puts us in check.
And if that was the case with Deere,
we would be fucked.
We'd go 20 miles an hour everywhere they'd be jumping in front of your car
everywhere you went.
The only good thing is we'd never go hungry.
You just pull over,
pull out a gun,
boom,
blow into those stupid fucking things.
The head start a fire and,
and just start.
You could eat,
you would never starve to death,
but there'd be deer everywhere and you wouldn't get anywhere and people would
die on the highway every day because you would just hit one of those fucking
dummies kick through your skull.
They fucking fuck you.
Oh the fuck your head up man.
Deer Jerky.
Love it.
Just because I don't have a box of it.
Oh really?
Yeah,
I get,
I buy a venison jerky and elk jerky.
Yeah,
I feel like a man when I eat them.
I feel like I'm on mountain men.
I'm living in a cabin.
You are fear some felling fierce as fuck.
Alright.
Cut.
Deers living in my yard bro.
I'm like a wild person up here.
A wild person got to be careful about wild though.
Okay.
I respect that shit.
Gonna keep it in line.
People that think that you shouldn't kill deer are ridiculous.
You're ridiculous.
And to do something with them ridiculous and you're dangerous.
Okay.
And it's stupid.
It's not like they're going to live forever if you don't shoot them.
And by the way,
killing deer is a thousand times better than running some ridiculous factory
chicken farm stuff and everything and do a fucking box where it can't move.
Or just thinking about veal,
you know,
thinking about how they raise veal and how,
how many pig farms or pigs or stuffed right next to is where the tears are just
running around man,
just running around.
I would like to do the bow hunting.
Dude.
I've been watching a lot of bow hunting.
It's cool,
but I don't think,
I can't actually,
I'm not,
I,
I'm not good at stomaching the,
I'll show you something I really won't like.
Really?
Yeah.
Wore this show called pig man.
And uh,
I've been obsessed with it from a,
to the time I saw them first kill a pig with a knife.
The dog's hold the pig down and they stabbed in the throat with a knife.
That's a show.
It yet show.
It's a hunting show.
It's about pigs in rural Texas.
Yeah,
pigs in Texas are fucking huge problem and wild pigs are like literally like
destroying millions of acres.
There's millions and millions of wild pigs.
They're ridiculous infestation to the point where they're shooting amount of
helicopters and that's one of the things they did on pig man.
This guy gets out a fucking helicopter and shoots like 200 pigs in a day.
Well this is the disturbing.
That was disturbing,
but the most recent episode was way more mustard disturbing.
He's going,
he goes hunting in Argentina and he's trying to get pigs like these big giant
pigs and there's no pigs around.
So he shoots off Fox and he shoots a Fox with a bow and Arrow and the thing
screams this horrible
and it was really fucked up man.
It was really,
it was really weird to watch because he nails this thing and it just lets out
this horrible,
horrible screech and then you realize he's not going to eat that.
You're not eating that Fox.
Like he just shot that Fox because he could shoot that Fox and I was like,
oh,
what for the pelts or something?
Jesus Christ.
What don't we don't we live in,
in the fur trapping days.
You know,
you're not really a fur trapper.
I mean I guess it's worth some money,
but you just shot that thing cause you wanted to shoot a fox and I,
when I lived in Colorado,
mem foxes are cool as fuck cause they're bad ass.
They're kind of cool man.
There's um,
what's it called?
Coyotes that run around the uh,
the uh,
like Griffith Park.
The coyotes are different.
Coyotes and creeps.
Okay.
It is in my big dangerous creeps.
They are,
they're dangerous creeps.
But foxes are not dangerous to people at all.
Coyotes will attack children,
but Fox says won't.
The foxes are coming packed.
Very clever.
They do coming back and they come in packs down from you.
They come down from the hillside and you'll all of a sudden,
like every few weeks I'll hear that.
That have like a maniacal high pitch barking danger.
Andress.
Yeah,
they're always in my front yard and they're,
they're,
they like play with my dog through the window.
Like my dog will bargain in that coyote will come out and just stupid.
Would I say about them?
Is that the only reason I don't kill us is because they don't think they can get
away with it.
That's all it is.
And they'll kill anything else around us,
including your children.
They will attack your children.
Was having a bunch of times I've seen,
I've seen a dog running like trodding a coyote,
excuse me.
Uh,
trodding down fountain with a dog and its mouth.
Oh yeah.
Oh yeah,
dude.
That's what they eat late at night.
They snatch him right off of people's leashes.
People go walking around in Nice neighborhoods like Brentwood that go walking
around with a dog on a leash and a coyote will come and snatch that motherfucker
off and run their rights out here.
Man.
The rats just walk on my power lines and you're just going from house to house.
He just,
Whoa,
that shit.
Fuck Oof.
I had had,
uh,
some guy,
they had a lockdown,
some house and quarantine it because some people caught some horrible rat
disease from that hoarder show.
Geez.
Yeah.
They're cleaning up people's houses and you know,
these people had a rat infestation in their house,
so they've taught in this disease.
Apparently it kills like 20 to 50% of the people who get it and it's incurable.
There's no cure for it.
So these people were catching this horrible incurable disease from cleaning up
people's shit houses,
Jesus rats everywhere and infestations.
And I used to see those rats on the power lines.
And this is when I worked in like a big corporate building.
And so I talked to the,
they had the guys would,
would come into the offices in the kitchen and like set traps and do this stuff.
So I was like,
Hey,
I,
you know,
I'm terrified of the fucking rats.
I was like,
what can I do about rats?
And he was like,
well,
you know,
he's telling me the options.
And he was like,
he gave me these,
uh,
these like
Gel pad,
like Sticky Gel.
Like it's like a,
it's like a big rectangular thing and you just place it and he's like,
there'll be running and then they'll just get stuck in that and then they just
rot and then they'll just die.
So I was like,
all right.
So I was so scared of them that I said fuck it.
I put it up on the roof and he's like put like a little peanut butter and it'll
just come right there.
Cool.
I lay them out,
I come out the next day they are from the roof.
They're down on the floor now.
Flipped over and shit on is like the rats pick them up,
flip them over and shit all over them like fuck your trap or real.
Yeah and they just,
they were just kicked over.
It might with rat shit all over them.
I had that really bad mouse problem when I was in college and like it's still
about where the mice were just like,
like I would take a blanket off my couch and mice would scurry out and blah.
What do you have like an ancient infrastructure that's been infested,
like New York City's infrastructure is really almost no way to eradicate them
unless you would clean every person out of the city and then just kill
everything alive and the city otherwise,
and even then you're probably going to miss a few.
They're going to be in crack somewhere hiding those naval cuts.
There's more brats I think.
Then there are people in New York City.
Yeah.
So we had one of those traps,
but my mouse,
like,
I was like,
well one day and he's like,
what's that noise in my kitchen?
And I hear like,
like I like just the shuffling noise and there's like just blood and there's a
mouse there that was like biting his leg off and I didn't know what to do.
So I grabbed like one of the scoops that you for the broom and I threw it
outside and I was like,
I don't care what's,
so I don't know what happened to it.
I just never went into my backyard anymore.
She,
yeah,
when you got anywhere but this rats,
you just gotta get the fuck out of there.
This is,
you can't win.
You're not going to win.
You need to set up shop in a place.
It doesn't have rats like that.
The monoxide house,
same house.
It makes sense.
Jesus Christ.
What a shitty house got attacked by rodents and poisoned brain to speaking of
poison brain,
this new sports illustrated.
I know you're a football fan.
She read this shit on Jim McMann.
No,
I know he's,
he's not doing well.
Not doing well man.
The Gym,
when I was a kid,
I was not a football fan,
but I knew who the fuck Jim Mcmahon was mean.
He was a super famous football player.
Bandanas and he used to wear a bull shark.
Yeah,
the Superbowl shuffle while he,
apparently he has dementia and uh,
he,
his girlfriend takes pictures of them together because one day she's worried
he's going to forget who she is because she sees it slowly slipping away.
Like he'll be,
he'll kiss her goodbye and they'll be downstairs just standing frozen because he
can't remember what he was going to do.
I think football is on the verge of changing dramatically.
How the fuck can you,
that's,
they were talking to him,
he was on another sports show and they were talking to him about it and he said
leather helmets might be the rule,
like go go to back to Lubbock leather helmets and have no head contact at all.
He said,
but that's not gonna work.
I mean it's like who's going to accept that?
Yeah,
I know.
I the um,
oh my God.
On real sports on HBO.
Yeah.
All those old players that come in shaking that,
I've seen that,
but they have this,
uh,
this guy,
I feel bad that I forgot his name,
but he played for the saints and he got als at like 34,
35.
And basically they said this is the first edit like time we've ever seen that
this traumatic just head door there.
The severe head trauma repeatedly might be a cause of als.
We've never had,
we've never shown evidence that something could lead to als.
What does als stand for?
Uh,
it's uh,
it's a long,
uh,
it's a medical term that I can't pronounce correctly,
but it's,
it's,
you know,
it destroys your muscles and the only thing it doesn't destroy as it eats away
your muscles is your brain.
So you're totally aware of how you're physically just brave,
evaporating.
And like they show,
he,
he played in the,
in the first game after Katrina,
New Orleans was,
was just devastated.
Right.
And they,
the super,
the super dome was used to house,
uh,
the city's residents who didn't have a place to go and they never know if they
were going to even be able to rebuild it.
They rebuilt it,
you know,
got it all cleaned up.
And then they had their first game since Katrina and it was like a big deal and
he blocked a punt that just like sent the place into.
It's like one of the craziest,
you see the clip of it is like,
it's super emotional place.
Just goes nuts.
They're so excited to have their team back.
And so he was that guy and he retired.
He played like eight or nine years in the league and was like,
you know,
retired and looking forward to the rest of his life.
How old was he when he retired?
He retired I think,
uh,
like 30,
31 years ago.
And then,
you know,
finally retired 31.
Uh,
he was just,
you know,
had his run,
like he wasn't,
you know,
he was a special teams player.
Like he had a good,
a good career.
And then,
but that seems like there's plenty of years left.
And your athletic career,
um,
a lot of,
you know,
NFL guys or three,
four years.
And is it because of physical?
We just set up that you just don't make the cut.
Yeah,
like a lot of times you'll see guys that they were like big contributors and
then you know,
their way by this team picked up by this team and all of a sudden they're 29
even.
And they're like,
they're,
no team wants them anymore.
Like there was so crazy.
Yes,
you were out.
You were out.
I mean it's so fucking,
you know those collisions man.
And they asked him during the thing,
they're like,
how many times were you knocked out during your career?
And he was like twice,
you know,
where I was like,
blackout knocked out.
And then how many times did you have like your Bell Rung?
You know,
where you're just like,
Holy Shit.
He was like hundreds,
hundreds of times.
It's written little practice.
Those cows,
those count too.
Practice counts,
everything counts.
And we see,
you know,
junior say out.
Uh,
I mean it's,
what do you do though?
Do you tell people that got to stop playing for,
I would not want my kids to play football.
Tell you that I would be reluctant.
I know that like the one thing that,
the only way,
I mean,
the thing that most people agree on is that the proper technique is,
is not being taught from a young age.
Now people are no longer like you look at old footage of football.
Yeah.
They're different caliber athletes and stuff and they're not like the monsters,
but like it was tech and it was more technical tackling people.
Would you taught when you know,
you,
you load your,
Bend your knees,
you put your shoulder into basically somebody's chest,
you wrap up and you tackle.
Those are the,
the tackles that rarely do you see that result in like some devastating had
drama.
But now it's,
and this is now like meaning the last 15,
20 years.
It is like,
you see helmets being lowered,
crown of the head into the other person's helmet.
Just head blows.
People are fucking,
you know,
throwing shoulders,
helmets and forearms into people's heads and then you see them just there.
It's like they were just in a car accident man.
Like they're just,
they can't handle it.
It doesn't matter what type of helmet you wear.
Yeah,
there's um,
there's only so much punishment your,
your brand can take.
And I think that there's very few things in life that hit you as hard as a
football player does.
I just think that those dudes,
when you look at a 300 pound guy running it,
you full clip and charging into your body while another guy hits you over this
way and you collide together and then the guy goes unconscious.
Like is there any other time in life where you see a man completely armored up
just getting knocked unconscious?
Oh my God.
They have helmets on.
They have big arm or padding on their shoulders and they get knocked the fuck
out knocked out and the real problem now there are low,
they're more on top of it cause they have to be.
But the real problem is you look at like eighties and nineties,
the guys who are now 40 to 50.
Yeah.
And you're seeing a lot of like depression,
um,
dementia,
dementia and you're seeing Alzheimer's and,
and all these different,
a debilitating things take place.
Those guys would get knocked out or you know,
they would get like a severe concussion and it would just be like,
you need to go play right away now.
Like there wasn't like now there's like,
you know,
they're finally doing like if you even have a sign of this,
you're going to be out for this amount of time.
You have to have those guys played with like full concussion syndromes,
which means that like their brain just went,
there's just shook inside their skull and now they're fucking playing again.
You know,
it's so crazy that they didn't even know.
It's like they,
that just shows you how recent,
not just the science of brain trauma is where they really kind of understand
what causes real problems,
but also the,
the,
the idea of this as a sport.
So recent and in the Human Medical Venay,
you know,
um,
uh,
encyclopedia a far as like things that happened to people.
How often did they have to like judge a or,
or,
um,
look at a very specific
group,
like people who do this one thing,
who all come down with traumatic brain injury.
Like,
what the fuck is going on?
What does this one profession,
you know,
it's not like being a welder does that,
but being it's football player thing.
Well,
this whole idea of a football player like a hundred years old,
I mean it's super new.
So we did in the medical history of like things that you shouldn't do that are
fucked up for you.
This sort of hasn't really been fully,
fully entered,
but neither has fighting man.
I mean,
fighting like in as far as like people have known about punchdrunk boxers
forever.
I mean that's always been,
you know,
the box has stuck around too long and that the horrible stories and the,
the list,
so the words that are,
you know,
stumbling,
slurring out of their mouth.
It's,
it's terrible to watch that stuff.
But we've,
we've known about that forever,
but we're going to start to see that probably from MMA fighters if they're,
they're not looked after Devin as well.
I mean,
they're,
they're taking shots to the head is wow.
It's all about knowing when to fucking get out.
Yeah.
It's all about using as much,
you know,
intelligence as he can risk as much as you need to,
but no more.
And then get out when you feel like it's slipping away and you got to treat,
you've got to treat.
Um,
any real like head trauma,
a concussion,
like a really serious event.
Like it's not something to just be like,
well that happens.
It gets really,
really serious.
Well I've heard a dude's get knocked out and training and then go to a fight and
then get hit with like a small shot in the fight and they go unconscious because
they were really like walking around like halfway knocked out already.
Yeah.
Marvin Eastman fought Travis Luder and Travis Luder hit him on the end of the
punch.
It was like,
it was a really weird,
it didn't look,
it looked like,
like he just shut off.
He like,
he hit him and his whole body and I was like,
that doesn't even make any sense.
But then you talked to the people that trained with and they said he got knocked
out twice in camp for that fight,
which is just fucking crazy.
And he was probably right back like the day after fucking taking shots when I
wonder if they're ever going to be able to fix that and wonder if it's ever
going to be anything that can repair.
Because the thing about brain conditions I think from impact is that the
degenerative and that,
just like with these boxers,
they say that something happened to them 10 years ago and they start to feel the
effects 10 years later.
Well I think,
you know,
because it's,
it's so unnatural either to get like the trauma.
Absolutely.
Like most people that have one occurrence like that,
that's the one occurrence they have for their life.
They don't have that.
They don't go through that hundreds of times.
You know,
you have somebody,
you know,
everyone knows somebody or you're in a car accident.
Oh fuck.
And it fucked me up.
And you know,
that's that one time that happened and I had headaches,
you know,
for fucking years.
And I went to this type of therapist and I got this type of treatment once,
not like,
oh I've,
this is the kind of thing that happens to me every six weeks.
I get fucking just laid out and fucking pass out because somebody's devastated
my head.
A lot of camps that didn't know any better.
They thought that that was tough and guys up so guys were getting knocked out
and training all the time cause they would go full clip and training.
That was like really common and a lot of camps,
you know,
I don't want to name names,
but yeah,
people um,
they don't,
don't treat brain trauma with as much respect as they should.
Yeah,
they did a lot of things fucked up.
I know they used to not believe that you should give like a football players
water when they're like an August generic like to toughen you up.
Like during practice feel like two and a half hours with no water.
It's like 98 degrees outside.
They thought that was like the smart thing to do.
They did a lot of stupid shit man.
They did a lot of stupid shit.
There's a lot of people out there that got a,
their brains ruined because people didn't understand.
And now,
now,
but,
but now it comes down to this.
Now we know.
Now what do we do?
Right.
It's cause it seems like you can fight in MMA and get out of it without brain
trauma.
I don't know if that's the case with football.
I really don't.
There's some guys that clearly have made it out okay.
But there's,
there's guys,
I think there's going to be this wave,
this wave of guys,
you're going to see where it's not just every once in a while you hear the news
of somebody.
It's going to be just dozens of people that have severe,
you know,
uh,
brain injuries from football.
You get rid of the helmets.
Yeah.
That's what they're saying is just that is,
we'll look,
it's a very bright suggestion and people think it's silly.
They're like,
what are you talking about?
That's even more dangerous.
It's actually not,
man.
That was also one of the arguments about MMA that they should switch to bare
knuckles because you can't punch people.
It was hard.
The only problem is you cut people a lot easier with your knuckles then he was
still,
a lot of,
a lot of fights would be stopped because of cuts,
elbows and knuckles cut people the most.
But um,
you can punch them and a lot harder if you've got a little gloves on.
If you've got padding on,
I mean the,
the helmet is used in football as a weapon.
It's just like when you talk about the,
the,
you know,
the gloves that are dipped,
your hand wrapped.
It's a web,
it's a fucking solid weapon and he's protected by all these pads.
So you can brace it against your,
you know,
your neck and everything and you're running full into somebody's.
Yeah.
So silly sport man.
It's as a human being.
I mean,
look,
it's super and if,
if,
and if that's how you make your living,
you know,
a God bless Ya.
You know what I'm saying?
God bless.
But if you've got another option,
man,
you might want to not slam your body and to dude's as hard as you can because it
seems like that Shit's bad for you and it's pretty it.
There's definitely a good argument against it because like a fighter like
Anderson Silva can go through whole fights and not get touched me.
Just fucks guys up and doesn't even get hit you and you look at it and go,
well,
if you're super talented and super technical,
you know you can fight and not take that much damage.
He goes through all Anderson's fights,
only the chill son and fight.
Does he ever take like a bunch of punches and they still looked fine at the end
of that and brain?
Why'd you think he's all right?
He's fine,
he's fine.
He's 100% fine.
There's nothing wrong with him,
but he's a,
also,
he's delicious.
He's a dishing out way more punches and more delicious punches he's taking.
He's just fucking people up so hard.
Yeah,
he,
he's,
I got a totally different confidence level than them.
He's on a totally different like striking speed wavelength.
He's just putting Beaton's on dudes,
man.
And so because of that,
he's not like taking much damage.
But then you see some other dudes that he's fighting,
you know,
some guys that he's fucking up and you gotta go,
man,
how many more fights like this can this guy have?
And every fighter has to sort of decide on their own,
they have to reach this sort of,
it's a tough,
tough thing to come to man.
Fuck out his time to dip out.
Yeah.
Especially if that's how you make a living.
How are you going to pay your bills and the um,
not to mention,
you know,
the,
the uh,
the rush they get of being like in the game,
you know,
being part of like prize fights,
and you're fucking in an arena and people are screaming when you ended up like,
that's a,
that's a rush you can't compare to anything you do in your regular fucking life.
Yeah.
There's nothing like that.
Nothing like that.
That's a hard thing to fucking put down.
It'd be super hard to find something that can come even close.
You'd have to be like a fighter pilot or some shit.
They say that that's a lot of people are saying.
That's what say,
oh like you know,
he played in the NFL for like 16 years,
which is pretty much unheard of.
Especially like as like a linebacker and that like he just was like,
he was depressed about not getting the,
that rush anymore.
You know,
being like in the,
in the Games we'll also,
he I considerable brain damaged.
Yeah,
definitely.
That's the thing man.
They say that brain damage,
they say once it fucks with your pituitary,
your brain's tops producing the right amount of testosterone,
you get depressed from that.
You know,
you get that.
There's a lot of different factors that can lead to like some pretty severe
depression because of brain trauma.
You know,
it's one of the arguments against testosterone replacement for um,
uh,
for fighters actually.
Is the traumatic brain injury a argument?
I don't,
I don't totally completely understand it,
but I think they're saying is if you get hit in the head and now it's like
James,
Tony was an example of it.
You get hit in the head enough and your,
your bond is not going to produce testosterone.
Same Way.
But then I've heard other doctors say,
and this kind of makes sense to me,
well,
hey man,
if you can't produce for testosterone anymore because he got hit in the head so
many times,
like maybe you should stop getting hit in the head.
That's a great,
yeah,
that's a great lesson.
You know,
it seems like that's the thing you should stop first.
Yeah.
Like forget about like trying to do anything to supplement your testosterone.
You got to stop getting hit in the head because your brain's going to stop
working.
She was like,
yeah,
my times can you hit your car with a hammer before the engine brakes.
It's like neat.
Nef you know there's a,
there's great footage of James Tony Sparring like a few years back and he's
like,
he's pretty out of shape in it and he talks shit don't hire time that he's
barring.
Yeah.
And he's like,
he's winded,
but he's just like bitch ass faggot.
Well,
he's sold technically talented James,
Tony,
his shoulder rolls and his ability to tie,
figure out where you're punching and block you and cover you.
He's a brilliant boxer,
man.
If you go back to hid the early days,
like when he knocked out Michael,
none.
[inaudible] James,
Tony's a God damn animal man.
He,
he's a power punch hours dude.
And he became a slick ass boxer.
He just didn't have the same motivation to training that like some other guys
did.
If he trained like Roy Jones Jr train.
Oh my God.
What a fight that was him and Roy Jones Jr.
That was a fucking great fight.
Yeah.
If he would have trained late like Roy Jones.
That was too bad.
It's too bad.
He never sort of recovered from that.
Did they fight again?
Did they ever fight again?
I don't know if,
if a twice,
I dunno.
I don't think they did it.
Why do I feel like,
why do I feel like they didn't?
But James Tony was one of the only like major guys that ever tried,
uh,
to,
get into MMA.
Oh yeah,
he did.
Yeah.
If all Randy coture,
how did that go then?
Go so good.
Randy.
Go towards just grabbed him and threw him on the ground.
Really wrangled them like immediately.
Was it like a ten second thing?
Uh,
yeah it was,
it was a joke.
Oh Jesus.
He took him down with a low,
a low single.
Got them in an ankle pick.
I guess they were trying to plan it.
They were trying to plan the second fight.
Oh really?
Yeah,
but I think James Tony might be a heavyweight now.
Big Boy.
Yeah.
Well they say that t yeah,
I think you said they might.
They say Tony is like 240 pounds and Roy Jones,
you know,
is still fighting,
but he fights it like cruiser weight sometimes or light heavyweights.
I'm not going to drop down.
I've been watching Roy John's fight to it.
It's depressing as shit.
I know it's not,
it's not like the old days.
It's not just like the old days is getting knocked out a lot.
Yeah,
seen him knocked out a couple of times.
He's a good analyst.
He's actually a good analyst.
I don't know why he doesn't just fucking,
you know,
he needs money,
man.
Apparently if you listen to the Internet,
they say that he's another one of those dudes that didn't pay his taxes.
He owes millions of dollars.
Well,
you know,
when someone tells you you don't have to pay or someone's a shitty his financial
advisor or you think you got everything covered and you know,
that's,
this is never gonna go away.
A lot of those guys don't have good accountants.
Ma'Am.
I know you kind of pay your money,
you got to pay.
I don't think we should pay as much as we pay,
but I think you've got to fucking pay you gotta pay if get,
I get a little pissed off when I find out about a guy that's been living high on
the hog and it was millions of dollars in taxes,
you know,
cause like we should all contribute.
We should.
There's a real,
I mean,
you know,
this Obama argument that everybody is upset at him because he said,
if you run a small business,
you didn't build that.
You didn't build the infrastructure.
He didn't build a street.
That's what he meant.
Like you didn't build a streets and everybody was upset by that.
But in the end,
a lot of ways that is true.
I mean we do need to pay,
everybody needs to pay a little bit of something.
It's just there should be some sort of an accounting should be able to find out
how you're spending.
The money shouldn't be so God damn wide open,
we have to give you money and then you'd do whether if you,
especially if you're guy like him,
I feel like how much money did that guy give them?
Roy Jones over the years and taxes and millions and millions and millions of
dollars.
Millions he should have.
Like if it gets a certain number and you should be able to say,
or this is what we did with your money,
we went over it and we use all of your millions to set up a base in Kosovo.
You actually set up a base over there.
That'd be really cool and people would be excited to know that shit.
What did I really,
would you think about like what Roy Jones spent stretching of acts?
It's not done.
That's going to be your shit.
Tommy Segura stretch of the highway.
It's not done yet.
If you look at,
um,
you know a guy like Roy Jones,
how much do you think he made?
It was,
it had to be,
man,
I want to say 100 million.
I say that's not that.
That's probably accurate probably around that.
Yeah.
So it out of $100 million,
let's get super crazy and say you have to pay 48%,
cause that's like the highest you can pay without tax shelters and all that
stuff that I'm sure a smart person would figure out or a good accountant.
So let's say he paid $48 million,
so let's just go nutty.
And B,
he used that as a number.
It's crazy.
48 million supports and army firmware.
That's like what did he,
what,
what country did they overthrow with
your shit?
That's your shit.
Roy.
Roy [inaudible] here with that body shot.
That's the jet sign.
Missiles and shit at yours,
right.
God Damn it really?
This is twice in one podcast does powerful Duncan Trussell it doesn't,
obviously we watch our podcast from that fucker Hump Day and Dunkin,
you can just get sent a voicemail.
I tell your,
uh,
your listeners to come and see me this weekend,
but you could,
you could say where you're playing,
but don't tell them to come see you.
Okay.
You could say if you would like to come see some comedy.
I was like,
hey man,
I was meaning it like that,
you know.
Uh,
um,
hey man,
if you like comedy,
you live in the,
uh,
like Orange County,
maybe area.
Where are you going to be this weekend?
Tell me Improv only or am only three shows.
Only three shows,
which was day,
Thursday and Friday night in to Friday night.
That's it.
Brian Improv as a fucking phenomenal club.
Have Fun there.
That's,
you know,
if you live in that area,
there's not a whole lot of shit going on other than the movies.
And there might be like a bowling alley or some shit.
Come see the g o,
D and B.
They're dodging coyotes,
but they do have the Improv.
The improv is fucking,
it's a,
it's a great club and every week they have like top level talent there.
If you look at the like the Improv's roster,
if you go by there,
what a great thing that is to have in your town.
Like if you,
you know,
one week it's this guy,
the next week it's Tommy Sigora.
The next week it's Ari.
You know,
Joey Diaz headlines,
the Improv's now too.
It's just,
it's such a great thing to have in your town and that Breyer and is one of my
favorites.
The first club I ever work.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Have you done sat there,
Brian?
Yeah,
I placed a fun club.
I placed is tremendous.
It's so good.
Joey was doing that dirty night there once a month,
but I think he got a too busy with all those little different side projects.
He's doing some step camp.
Joey Diaz has a new podcast to ladies and gentlemen.
If you're big Joey Diaz,
his fans,
it's called the Church of what's happening now and it's on iTunes and it was
like top four like right away of course course.
Cause Joey Diaz is the one of the most fascinating human beings ever.
He's a monster.
We did Santa Barbara this weekend.
Holy Shit.
Is that fucking fun?
Where do you do with it?
Word the Lobero theater in Santa Barbara.
There's a lot of celebrities there.
A lot of celebrities,
man.
Yeah.
So like just a bunch of celebrities live and that's what we saw.
Carol Burnett.
But yeah,
a lot of celebrities live out there.
It's beautiful.
The weather's never,
it never like is not perfect.
It's gorgeous out.
People are Nice.
It's like really nice houses,
old houses,
houses like around from the 1920s he should like that.
It's just a gorgeous,
gorgeous,
a primo place to live,
man.
Beautiful,
beautiful place.
And did people seem like a little bit more chill there?
You know,
here we are.
We're so trapped in this fucking nutty hive.
You.
So it's so crazy and fast that I think that,
I think that shit gets away from you,
man.
I think we're better off when he's just a little less people and Santa Barbara
Man.
Fucking amazing.
Amazing brain as super train that goes from Santa Barbara to la in like 10
minutes.
You say that Bro.
But you know what Dunkin and I did.
We made a podcast.
I'll give it to you today so we can upload it.
But we just said,
you know what,
let's just make a podcast.
So I clipped my iPhone to my,
um,
my BMW has one of those little a cup holder things.
Yeah.
And the three ladies and gentlemen,
German engineering and as a sort of couple of the thing.
And I clipped my phone to it and we just did a podcast on my phone and it sounds
great.
I mean it doesn't sound like this,
but it sounds like totally,
you can hear what we're saying and it's kind of cool.
That's right.
Because it's like our first podcast in the car.
But yeah,
you do that.
You do that.
It just an hour drive.
So you go with a buddy,
you know,
you say you're going to do a show in Santa Barbara,
and you need to start doing that,
man.
You know,
but branch out,
you can do shows everywhere.
Now you're,
you're at the point now Brian's come with me to Sacramento.
Brian's at the point he could be in fucking professional standup comedian.
He's like right there.
Right.
You're right there.
If you just push a little right now you're,
you're,
you're a professional comedian.
Yeah.
Like you can do that.
You end,
you have a built in audience.
Like you'd be crazy not to do it.
Yeah,
you really would.
But he would totally be crazy not to do it.
Cause you can do it.
You get laughs.
You have some funny shit man.
That fucking,
I don't want to say the joke is it gives it away.
But that one Joe,
I love that joke.
That's a great joke man.
If you just kept,
you know,
chopping away at it and uh,
and,
and did it all the time and you could go,
you go on tour,
you could do,
we could promote your shows.
Like,
that's ultimately what I think would be awesome if everybody came in and were
promoting your shows,
were promoting your shows.
We could all be doing shows like all across the country of course,
and use this as like sort of a platform.
Come here during the week.
Everybody fucks around.
Everybody goes and does their shit on the weekend.
Yeah,
that'd be awesome.
But this,
uh,
you know this using the podcast to,
you know,
to work as like a promotional platform for standup comedy shows the concrete.
It's fucking thing ever.
It's awesome.
It's people really get to know you.
Tommy Button.
They do not like you sit on it tonight.
Show couch and gentleman on
my podcast is the most fun that I,
that I have doing anything.
It's cool that you do yours with your wife and you actually still like each
other.
We love it man.
We love each other.
We have the most fun.
If you guys had a lot of fun poop podcasts I've ever heard,
it's not just poop guys.
No,
but you were a guest.
You were a guest recently and we got to get you to,
I wasn't allowed to.
I would love to.
I'm doing a Dunkin's tomorrow,
but I'll do yours one day next week.
That'd be actually,
I'm trying to get a rich roll.
Who's the uh,
the uh,
Vegan,
um,
activist because people have been saying you got to get like vegans so we get
this.
But he's a is an athlete and I got Mac Dan's like also,
which is on Thursday,
who was another Vegan and I have good friend of mine,
he's a Vegan lunch today.
All right.
That this is in response to like vegans who are saying,
well you need to get someone to do a counterpoint to Robb wolf cause Robb Wolf.
I had the Paleo Diet Guy Peale,
the author of the Paleo Solution,
coffee,
bacon and eggs for breakfast.
I was like,
oh my God,
I want to blow you.
I was like,
I'm eating Kale shakes every day trying to stay healthy.
And this guy says coffee bic and an accident.
But I tried it,
but I'm telling you it's not correct.
The year you have this heavy feeling of like,
it's like,
Ooh,
let's take the cigarettes for
the coffee's supposed to counteract,
but it can't fuck with Kale shakes.
These kit,
the my morning Kale shake is just,
it's either that for me or hemp shakes,
that's all I drink in the morning and I have lots of energy,
like plenty of energy during the day.
I think we have,
I think we have to be careful about how much stupid shit we put in our bodies.
And I would rather have no like putting nothing in there then stupid shit.
Not that big and an is necessarily stupid shit.
It's delicious.
And I think your body processes fat and all that stuff.
It can process all those things.
It's all natural,
but it's not as,
it doesn't give you the same like clean feeling as like starting off with a
vegetable shake.
Yeah.
So I'm going to have this guy,
we're going to talk to heads.
Cool.
That's cool.
And you know,
he'll,
he,
cause he wanted to express himself.
He wanted to explain what the fuck is wrong with all these crazy mediators we
had.
We had,
we had red band on and we also,
uh,
if you guys go to your mom's house podcast,
if you check out mine,
we also had Yoshi on tell the story of when he ate.
Um,
Joey's banana bread and it's fucking know she has a bunch of crazy stories.
How about when he accidentally put acid in his eyeballs?
That story too.
Yeah,
it's fantastic.
Yeah.
It was at a friend's house and the dude had an eye dropper and a,
he didn't know there was acid in the eye dropper and you needed to clean his
eyes.
So he was back in Japan because in Japan,
eight drops of acid in his eyes,
which is like,
it's unheard of.
You know,
somebody told me the other day,
uh,
that,
that Joey Diaz did that to Jay more like,
like at a party really tricked him.
And in saying that that was acid and Jay Moore was like freaking out.
Like that's some other comic told me to.
So I don't know if it's true or not.
As long time ago,
like a long time ago.
Yeah.
You're going to start another campus.
I don't know if that's a more is going to be mad at you again.
Supposedly the story goes that Jay Moore was really freaking out.
He was,
he was fucking with him though.
Yeah.
And Jodi has was fucking with him the whole time.
It wasn't acid,
but like Jay Moore was freaking out because he was like,
what does that really acid?
What does that really,
well,
that's like what we were talking about,
the,
uh,
God,
I don't remember what the phobia is.
Were you there that people,
um,
I really wish I could remember the word because I looked up the word that I
thought it was not,
it's not Ella phrenia,
Ella phrenia.
Is that right?
No,
it isn't that what I said already,
that that's about the someone's crazy and you're around them kind of thing,
that,
that thing,
you know?
I mean,
it kind of makes sense that if someone starts treating you like you're crazy.
Yeah.
That makes sense.
And you're like,
oh,
and then you start to maybe a dad,
like you start to act in the behavior that they've,
their conditioning you to acton.
You know what I mean?
My ex girlfriends.
Is that what you,
that's how you control them.
Jets.
I'm crazy.
And then grades event and stick your penis inside of them until it,
until it doesn't feel good anymore.
And then blame everything on them.
And then what else is the move?
Get Fat.
That's a good move.
That's how you get rid of him.
So,
uh,
anyway,
I'm going to offer the Vegan point of view,
uh,
because I,
I think,
uh,
I shit on vegans enough and uh,
there's a lot of people up.
Why can't people just eat me?
And if you want to eat a little Vegan,
like I consider Vegan,
like I'm eating Italian tonight.
Yeah,
they don't though.
That's what's fascinating about it.
It's a,
it's sort of,
it's a lifestyle choice.
It's a,
you know,
you're making a decision that you don't want to do anything that's going to harm
the environment.
You don't want to do anything that's gonna make your footprint larger.
It's kind of,
I see the point,
I just,
someone's going to kill the animals.
The,
the,
you have to kill them.
Oh glass.
You're going to start sterilizing them at birth and then who the fuck are you to
play doctor?
You can just chop off a deer's balls.
You've got to kill him.
I'm going to bring Fogo de Chao that day.
I'm just going to eat this today.
Who Little Shit did you son of a bitch and said don't do that.
What about the smell of burning meet is to like a person who's a super hardcore
Vegan?
Probably nauseates them.
I'm sure you know they're not supposed to have honey.
Why not?
Because bees are slave.
Oh fuck on that man.
Fuck that shit.
I got 10 minutes on vegans in my new a new hour.
Oh,
it's quite be 10 minutes.
That's great.
That's just so,
there's so much silliness we get.
It's almost like being a Mormon and vegans like right up there with being a
Mormon.
It's like at the,
at the end of it you're like,
wait,
wait.
You wait.
And what?
Bees.
Bees are slaves.
It seems so extreme.
Men.
And I saw a guy who like trying to encourage someone from to Vegan.
Hey,
don't worry about that man.
Don't let honey stopped you from being a Vegan.
I mean,
Hey,
I don't,
I don't use it for,
don't let that stop you.
Oh,
I don't use it.
I am super ultra perfect via man accused the honey that honey man means like
bees have souls,
man.
Like why put him to work?
Why?
Why steal their work,
man?
I mean,
how's that any different than what she accused Carlos Mincey of doing that.
Okay.
He's just taking the honey from these beans.
Shut your fucking stupid face.
His stupid fucking asshole.
You're telling me that we can't figure out honey and it's delicious.
Honey is awesome.
We don't have to make it.
These dumb cunt insects make it.
Can we steal it from them?
The way we steal it from there was with smoke,
these fucking stupid ass holes and then they will blow smoke on them.
Then you scoop them up with a kitty litter shovel and you put them in a box and
you close the stupid box and they buzz around for a little while and then you
take all their fucking honey and you hack off those little babies that are
growing in there.
You get the fuck out of here.
This little embryos that are in there cut all that shit out.
That's not necessary.
Just kept me to that honey spot is bare likes.
Here's the hive.
Is all the embryos and the honey altogether in the same thing?
I think so.
I don't know cause that was always fascinating when I was a kid and I would find
a beehive on the ground that you do that and like open them up.
Yeah.
How weird was that?
When you see them in the little shuttle,
the little fucking pop.
They mean they're just like the alien.
They're just really tired.
They're miniature aliens.
Yeah.
Especially if you watch them fuck up other insects.
Queen especially wasps.
Yeah.
There's a crazy documentary where it details this one wasp attack where they
came in and killed these honeybees and it was an enormous wasp.
They were way bigger than the honeybees and it just comes in and just starts
cutting the heads off the honeybees
and these,
this one swarm,
this like thousand fucking honeybee colony was killed by like 30 of these wasps.
And it is fucking tough to watch man.
These,
I mean he's just like,
what,
what would we do if these things were our size?
Oh man,
he wouldn't do Jack Shit.
I had wasp,
I got up,
I walked into a wasp nest one time like in Berwyn was and they just fucking,
it stayed in my arm.
Like I was like fucking yes.
Stabbing.
Yeah.
And they,
um,
the thing about bees too,
I found out that the queen has a stinger,
you know,
the Queen Bee has a stinger,
but she only uses it to kill Queens.
Oh really?
Yeah.
They use it to kill virgin queens.
They use it when you,
when you find a new queen,
like when someone's getting together and putting together a new queen.
Yeah.
You got to Jack that bitch or she'll come to take your spot because it can only
be like one queen the nest.
So they don't use it just on,
um,
on Queens when they're out,
they'll fuck up queen embryos.
They'll fuck up.
What do they,
what are they called?
What does it feed is,
what is the,
I don't know the term for an insect fetus and the idea of Brian is it,
it's not an embryo rather than write whatever the fuck it is.
Uh,
the,
uh,
the infant thing inside the honeycomb,
they stabbed him in the side and that's how they know when they've been attacked
by another queen.
Like she knows there's a hooker in that box.
She's going to go,
so just stabs it with her ass.
And so that's what they're hooked.
Their stingers for.
Their stingers,
not a stinger that injects venom.
It's just a sore sore to kill the babies.
We're so lucky.
They're little,
those huge evil fucking cons.
Um,
yeah,
it's fucking Fuck B's.
We need to figure out a way to get honey through little robots,
little tiny ass robot bees.
We should make drones that look like bees make honey.
And how about we make drones and just look like B's except they're way stronger
and harder and they come in and fuck all the bees in front of their boyfriends.
Imagine it'd be like robot bees with giant robot be dicks like dog,
like a steaming dog size.
Fuck.
Well,
and just,
we would have to have shotguns and fly swatters everywhere.
It just,
yeah.
Big Mace fly.
Swatters if they did fab you just like goes for through your back.
You'd be fucked.
I need,
yeah.
Size of a one the size of a softball would kill you.
Oh yeah.
Just fuck your day up.
Yeah.
I mean imagine just some value from,
from the,
from the fucking eat you alive.
Oh shit man.
Make babies in your body.
That's a movie.
I want to fucking see that movie Tommy bonds.
You're the best.
Thanks for having me.
Thanks for me on anytime,
man.
I was glad it was glad to do it.
I want to and we got to do it.
I mean,
and in a nonsexual way.
Um,
I was thinking,
man,
when was the last time we did a podcast with Tom?
He funds,
I wouldn't have you on soon.
And I also want to come back,
uh,
cause I have a new album coming out.
When are you,
um,
what are you doing tomorrow night?
Tomorrow night.
What is tomorrow?
Wednesday night chilling.
You want to do the Ice House with us?
Sure done ladies and gentlemen.
So now,
tomorrow night at the Ice House,
it is Joey Diaz.
It is Brian Callin.
It is Duncan Trussell and it's Tommy motherfucking buns and I believe Brian Read
Ben will be coming down to actually smoke the peace pipe with Duncan Trussell.
It should be an epic desk squad event,
Ladies and gentlemen.
So come on down and if you want to look fashionable when you're there,
you're going to want to buy eight death squad team shirt and you go to desk,
quad,
Dat TV.
And what you said,
what does this money go to?
Well,
for money all goes to support the desk squad podcast network,
which is on iTunes.
If you go,
there's a bunch of different podcasts there.
There is the icehouse chronicles that we do at the Ice House,
which is one of my favorite podcasts of all time because it's us.
It's all of like the,
the guys who are in town that combined to do shows.
Doug Stan hope has been on Tom Rhodes,
I'm sorry,
I was on it trying to,
girl has been on a Ian Edwards,
so it'd be me.
So many,
so many funny comedians and of course Ari and Joey and,
and we,
we put on these,
uh,
once a week,
twice a week sometimes.
And it's like really of the most fun shit that we do.
We get to fuck around and we get to loosen up before we go on stage and make a
podcast at the same time and,
and,
and make each other laugh.
And then we've been doing these shows at the ice house that are like literally
some of the funniest shows that I've ever done in my life.
And the,
the club couldn't have been cooler.
It's,
it couldn't be a more positive Karma space.
You know the ice house has been around since like the 1961 or something crazy
like that.
It's an old fucking club and it just the,
you mean you stand in the room?
The,
the,
the comedy room.
Like when the doors are closed and the lights are off and that place is,
it's buzzing.
It's got energy for like 50 fucking years of comedy in that place.
That's,
that's a,
that's an unusual place.
Yeah.
And I love that fucking second stage room too.
They're both awesome.
The little rooms.
Awesome.
The little room might be the best little room in the country.
Yeah.
It's super small.
It's tight knit,
but they're all like right there.
And his two tiers,
which is really rare in a small room.
That little room is amazing.
And it's might be one of the best rooms ever for coming up with new shit.
For just fucking around and coming up with new material.
Absolutely.
Which we'll be doing Wednesday night,
ladies and Gentlemen With Joey Diaz Aka mad.
Fuck you got a con badge maybe?
Oh we got a male.
Yeah.
Well,
I think that I was at the dentist and all my medicine,
it's like Warren often and I think I have like this migraine or something going
on that.
What did they have to drill my trying to get came on done.
Uh,
ouch.
We going on a cop or something?
No chewing gum.
Chewing gum.
I got a pee.
They tell you not to.
Tommy,
why don't you go pee?
Where could people go see you?
Where are you at this weekend?
Uh,
Bria Improv for brain Thursday and Friday,
Thursday and Friday.
Tommy boats.
Tom Cigarette outcome has all my,
the list thing you can,
I can send you notifications of Tom,
s e g u r a.com and you could follow Tom on Twitter.
Also seg.
You are a you dirty bitches shirt podcast,
the new top dog shirt.
I love it.
Come check it out.
Tomorrow I will be doing the Duncan Trussell family hour.
So no,
no.
Uh,
Joe Rogan experience podcast and then a Thursday I'll be back with Mac Dansik.
So uh,
that should be a lot of fun.
And a Wednesday night,
we are a at the ice house.
And this Friday night I'm in Sacramento with Brian Rare Blam Blam AAA.
Uh,
and it's,
um,
it's sold out,
so go fuck yourself.
So,
uh,
unless you're coming and then I didn't have you see or anything that,
no,
no.
It's just,
just in and out.
Yeah,
just one.
And it's,
um,
I just decided to just drop into a,
I never get down to Sacramento,
you know,
it's a,
it's a cool city,
but I'm hardly ever there.
And,
uh,
I don't remember what the name of the places,
I think that Chris Theater,
I think the crest theater I should,
it's really nice theater.
What we'll find out.
Um,
and then next week is the week after that is Toronto.
I met Massey Hall and I understand that there's a,
some ridiculous scalping going on and that people are telling me that the
tickets are like 300 bucks.
I ate something weird the other day about the Vegas.
One of your shows that was canceled.
Yeah.
And they charge like ridiculous amount of money extra for some reason.
And then when they took,
uh,
when the,
when the show got canceled,
they dev,
they didn't get the whole amount back.
Really?
What'd you hear this?
Fuck you told me this.
Somebody in Columbus,
Ohio.
It was a one of the guys from,
so there's like a cancellation fee or something like that.
Even though it wasn't there,
they didn't cancel,
right.
The venue cancer.
And they say it was like something like this guy's like,
add a lot of mine.
I need to find out what the,
that might be not correct or correct.
I don't know.
We'll have to find out.
But,
uh,
anyway,
folks,
listen,
thank you very much for,
for everything.
You guys are the fucking coolest human beings we've ever come in contact with.
You know,
we,
we talk about it all the time.
I mean,
uh,
Aubrey talks about it when he deals with customers at on it and,
we talk about it when,
when we do these comedy shows where we're lucky as fuck man,
and just whatever we're sending out there,
the fact that you guys are picking it up in such a positive way and responding
in such a positive way.
I mean,
there's no way to say this without sounding Super Corny,
but it's enriched the fuck out of all of our lives.
It's made us feel like we're really connected to something that can really help
and change the way people feel and don't,
don't think we think that is a,
in any small way.
Um,
uh,
I did just don't think that we ever take it for granted.
It's a,
I don't,
it's a weird thing to talk about it because it's,
um,
the,
the whole,
it's,
it's a,
it's a very strange situation to find yourself in it when,
you know,
we just started doing this podcast just fucking around and you know,
thinking we're just going to talk shit and put on the Internet and maybe people
would giggle.
And then having people come up to me,
like everywhere I go telling me now I've,
I've lost 50 pounds.
I started doing Jujitsu,
I changed my life,
started reading the war of art.
I didn't shoot myself.
We hear that all the time.
That's the scary one.
That's one of the scary ones.
And you know,
people that said they,
they don't have anybody like us near them.
And it's not that they don't think like us,
they think just like us.
They,
they're,
they're free thinkers.
They're open minded,
they're trying to be nice to people.
It's just sometimes we are defined by our environment,
but no long,
you fucks.
Now we're all connected by this crazy thing.
And,
uh,
this podcast is a big part of it for us,
and we know that it's a big part of it for you,
and we don't take that for granted in any way and we love the fuck out of you
guys,
so thank you very much.
Thanks for all the positive vibes,
all the positive tweets,
all that good shit.
And I'll see you guys on Thursday.
All right.
How much love,
okay.